well he's hosted one of the world's most
downloaded podcasts but adam carolla
says that hollywood's fiddling with the
relevant cancelled culture issues while
the world burns from real stuff like the
threat of putin global food shortages
and the cost of living crisis and adam
carolla joins me now adam great to have
you on piers morgan on sentence how are
you i'm well thanks for having me i
can't think of anybody better equipped
to appear on a show called uncensored
than you
where do you see the world right now
because i've got a theory that the
pandemic
now war
other seismic events have basically sent
a lot of people completely nuts
destroyed our perspective
uh you have culture wars raging as real
wars are raging
and you're based in hollywood the kind
of epicenter
of hypocrisy in many ways and also in
lacking perspective
yeah well it is you know may you live in
interesting times
somebody once said and i think
maybe they're too interesting
right now hollywood is
you know the land of make-believe
there's no real problems that people in
hollywood have but they do manufacture a
lot of problems and so you have to sort
of
live i mean if you think about
los angeles los angeles is
you know malibu and beverly hills and
the palisades and these multi-million
dollar homes and
multi-millionaires and
then you have homeless people just
living in their own filth on the ground
and that's kind of where we're at there
the middle is kind of gone we have ultra
poor and and ultra rich and and maybe
that's sort of a metaphor for
you know what where we're at in society
we have the ukraine on one side and then
on the other side we have a johnny depp
amber heard trial and it's all competing
for our attention
and when you involve social media in
this which didn't exist you know when
you and i like 20 years ago you didn't
have social media but now social media
seems to me to have whipped everybody
into an almost permanent state of
tribalism you know you have to belong to
a tribe and then you regardless of facts
you have to stick with the tribe
whatever it may be and that might be
about trump or it might be about brexit
over here or it might be about putin and
ukraine it might be about you know
vaccines whatever it is
very tribal now this debate in public
and very visceral and and toxic
yeah i agree and it's also
intellectually disingenuous you know you
know you you take covid i live in
california we're still under an
emergency order we locked everyone down
we shut down all the small businesses we
shut down all the schools and if i raise
my hand and say
hey i got a couple of kids and they're
in high school and you just sent them
home for a year and a half i don't think
there's a real danger here for young
healthy people
maybe schools should be open then you
become a covid denier
that's that's where we're living as if
anyone is denying covet who what even is
a cova denier like who have you met a
human being that denies covet not a cove
denier i'm a coveted realist i i believe
you should
shut down the you know old age homes or
the nursing homes or take precautions
with the you know medical
first responders and blah blah blah but
don't shut the schools down and you know
i have elderly parents they should get
vaccinated my 13 year old son shouldn't
get vaccinated why does that make me a
denier
yeah i mean i think that what's
interesting about the pandemic and i saw
this with many other issues
is that people got extremely
self-righteous about their positions on
this and simply wouldn't change when
facts changed you know i think there was
an argument uh very early on in the
pandemic for lockdowns purely on the
basis that nobody knew what we were
dealing with and a lot of people were
dying very quickly but the moment we got
into a territory of successful vaccines
and therapeutics i changed my mind about
that and saw no need to ever do a
lockdown again on covid because we now
had proper protection
but i saw so many people who couldn't
get out of being almost hysterical about
lockdowns as they were about masks and
so on
almost driven again by a fear of
changing their mind because facts have
changed
yeah well it's a lot of
there there's definitely psychosis going
on and most of it is
narcissism i mean i all roads just lead
to narcissism most these people you're
dealing with are insane narcissists some
are politicians who are trying to
rewrite history but
mainly it's people who are just wrong
who don't want to go back and they
certainly don't like it when you point
that out and if you think about
most of the people that got thrown off
of twitter or many of these other
platforms for ideas they had about covet
most of them were right about two weeks
later after they were thrown off of
these platforms so
we are living in this sort of mass
denial now and i don't know if it how
how
virulent it is in britain but in the
united states it is it is something
to deal with well it's getting that way
here about everything um i want to talk
to you also about cancer culture you
haven't been cancelled you've got a
hugely successful podcast but you've
certainly run foul of hollywood because
if you don't play the rules that they
set down
and you really want to exercise your
right to free speech and to have your
own opinions
that doesn't lead to much popularity in
hollywood
no they
are probably as hived off as any
group there is you know if you really
think about groups you think about
republicans and democrats and
progressives and conservatives or what
have you right to lifers women's rights
you know all that but hollywood
as is as lockstep as a group is ever
going to get on just about every social
issue issue and the second
you run afoul of them or you cross that
line or you have any opinions that vary
from theirs then they lock you out and
they want to de-platform you and they'd
like to remove you from your livelihood
these are the same people that never
stop complaining about mccarthyism
practicing it in real time so of course
they're hypocrites were you encouraged
at all by the way spotify in the end
stood by joe rogan and netflix stood by
dave chappelle did you feel
a slight wind turning
yeah i mean i feel like we'd hit our
saturation point and it's unfortunate
that we have to hit our saturation point
before the ship starts to turn around
you know i've said that
a million times it's sort of like
new york
in the 70s in the early 80s had to be so
dangerous and so crime ridden that at
some point they bottomed out and then
they went and changed direction and went
more law and order and california is in
the process of bottoming out and then
will change direction and head towards
something that is more pragmatic and
makes sense but as i say all the time
why do we have to bottom out
why can't we just see where this is
going in advance and go hey i think i've
seen enough here yeah completely sort of
bottom out and now that we've kind of
bottomed out and there's an economic you
know aspect to it netflix disney
whomever they've realized that alienated
alienating half the country is probably
not a great business model well
especially when your sense of morality
doesn't extend
to outside of america so you go to war
with florida and a governor there over a
supposed anti-gay bill which never says
anti-gay but you won't you won't say
anything in protest about the oppression
of uyghur muslims in china because you
want the box office you won't stop
streaming to countries where it's
literally illegal to be gay and i think
it's the double standard on the on the
morality which i find so ridiculous
100
correct you know the nba does it disney
does it hollywood does it
yes they're
you know they'll attack
hobby lobby for not
providing
the morning after pill for their
employees or something but they have
nothing to say about middle eastern
cultures that are throwing gays off the
rooftops of buildings and killing them
now you talked about changing minds and
reflecting perhaps on
staunchly held opinions which you then
revised i wanted to play you an opinion
that you expressed in 2011 adam listen
to this
whose piers morgan by the way and who
decided in advance we're all in love
with this limey he's okay
i mean piers you want to keep the i'm
better than pierce morgan you're better
than pierce more why is this thing
nobody can do what i do shut up you
blowhard hey we have chubby guy in his
50s from england who we've never heard
of fever
now adam i want to give you the chance
to repent
or double down i knew that was coming
pierce i knew i knew it was coming
all right first things first i like you
secondly i didn't know who you were back
then thirdly i was blindsided by that
question that was not in our rundown he
just pulled that out of his butt in the
last second i only have one complaint i
was i was not in my 50s when you said
that but i am now that's my only
complaint the rest of it the rest of it
falls under my umbrella of free speech
you gave a perfectly honestly held
opinion at the time that i was a
blowhard you'd never heard of and i
should you actually went on to say i
should be driven out of town and sent
back to london which is where i'm
speaking to you from now
very prescient of me
adam it's great to talk to you i'm a big
fan uh i love the way that you go about
your business i love the way you speak
your mind i love your podcast it's a
great uh honor to have you on the show
thank you very much
thanks beers